مشاهدينا نعود مره اخرى الى ميناء جدا
اسلامي الذي يشهد وصول سفينه امريكيه
عسكريه قادمه من السودان ومعنى مراسل
العربيه عن الصفيه اهلا بك هاني ويبدو ان
الركاب السفينه بداوا من نزول منها الان
تفضل
صحيح صحيح صحيح نعم الاحصائيات الكامله
لركاب هذه السفينه الذين تم اجلائهم من
بورت سودان الى ميناء جده الاسلامي 222
عندما نفصل هذه الارقام اذا نستطيع ان
نقول 61 طفلا على متن هذه السفينه
العسكريه
الحربيه وهناك 63 راكب من الجنسيه
الامريكيه واعلى الجنسيات على متن هذه
السفينه هم من السودان بمائه من الجنسيه
السودانيه بمئه وسته وثلاثين راكب وكذلك
من سلوفانيا اربع اشخاص وايضا من المانيا
اربعه اشخاص
والمملكه المتحده شخص واحد وارتريا ثلاثه
اشخاص والسويد هناك ثلاثه اشخاص وكندا شخص
واحد واثنين من الجنسيه الفرنسيه
وخمسه من الجنسيه السويسريه هذه اللحظات
الاولى التي ترصدها الان كاميرا العربيه
لنزول الركاب البالغ عددهم
222 وكما تحدثت ان على الجنسيات التي
تحملها هذه السفينه الامريكيه الحربيه هي
من الجنسيه السودانيه 106
شخصا طبعا هم الان بداوا في النزول وكذلك
توجههم مباشره الى الحافله التي تقلهم الى
المقر المخصصه والمقر اماكنهم المخصصات
طبعا هناك بعض القنصليات والسفارات التي
تستقبل رايها وكذلك هناك جهد امنيه
وعسكريه وكذلك طبيه من قبل السعوديه هم
يتواجدون في استقبال هؤلاء الرعايه الذين
وصلوا علامه سفينه امريكيه حربيه وهي
تعتبر السفينه الثانيه التي تقوم بها
امريكا ولعلها ان هذه السفينتين التي اتى
جاءت متاخرتين في بعض وتعتبر هذه
السفينتين هي اخر السفن التي جاءت في وقت
متاخر منذ بدء عمليات الاجلاء خاصه اذا
سبقها فرقاطات هنديه وكذلك فرقاطات عسكريه
من الصين وكذلك سفن تجاريه
اجنبيه اضافه الى سفينه فرنسيه وكانت تلك
العمليات بدات منذ الرابع وعشرين من ابريل
من الشهر الماضي طبعا اليوم نحن نتحدث عن
جنسيات كما تحدثت عن هناك قرابه السبع
الجنسيات تحملها او ثمان جنسيات تحملها
هذه السفينه عدد الاطفال هم 61 طفلا ولا
بوادر الاطفال الان هم يظهرون على كاميرا
العربيه سواء من تحمله والدته او الذي
الذين يسيرون على اقدامهم وايضا نشاهد
الجنسيات المختلفه ايضا الجنسيه التي بدات
في النزول هي من السودان وكما تحدثت ان هي
اعلى جنسيه تحملها هذه السفينه العسكريه
الامريكيه بعدد بعدد يصل الى مئه وسته
وثلاثين راكب من رعايه السودان والذين
قدموا من بورسودان الى منى جده الاسلامي
هذه ابتسامه طفل ولعلها ابتسامه فرح
وابتسامه ايضا وصول السلامه
وامان خاصه ان ايضا والدتهما هي سعيده
وكذلك واضح الفرح ايضا على محياه خاصه بعد
وصولها الى ميناء جده الاسلامي والتقاء
المحبه والتقاء الطفوله بهذا الطفلين
الجميلين ايضا عمليه المواصله في نزول
الرعايه لم تظهر حتى الان الجنسيات الاخرى
التي تحدثنا عنها سواء الالمانيه او
السويديه او كذلك من المملكه الم شخص واحد
الان هو يظهر امامنا وهو من المملكه
المتحده وصل وهو شخص واحد فقط من المملكه
المتحده نزل برفقه الجنسيه
السودان وايضا هناك لا ننسى ان هناك
جنسيات اخرى من رايه اثيوبيا وايضا ارتريا
والسويد وسلوفانيا والسويسرا وهذه اللقطات
التي نتحدث عنها هي اللحظات الاولى طبعا
هذه السفينه هي سفينه انزال امريكيه فقط
هي مخصصه
لعمليات وصعود او عمليات عسكريه سواء عبر
حمل الاليات العسكريه والدبابات او كذلك
حمل للجنود الذين دائما ما تنفذ هذه
السفينه عمليات عسكريه ولكن في مثل هذه
المهمه الطوارئ اليوم امريكا تستخدم هذه
لاجلاء رايها من بورسودان الى ميناء جده
الاسلامي ما زلنا نواكب عمليه نزول الركاب
ما زالت ايضا رعايه الجنسيه
السودانيه تقوم بالنزول ما زالت اي وما
زلنا ايضا ننتظر الجنسيات الاخرى التي
ذكرناها ولعل ايضا في هذا المنظر هي مشاهد
لاعداد كثيره من الاطفال وتحدثنا عنها ان
هناك
قرابه الثلاثه وستين طفلا على متن هذه
السفينه او بالاصح 61 طفلا على متن هذه
السفينه واضافه الى الجنسيات الاخرى وهي
الاعلام من رعايه السودان بعدد 136 تليها
الجنسيه الامريكيه بعدد 63 راكبا علامتنا
هذه السفينه طبعا هناك مراحل اخرى سوف
ينتقلون اليها هؤلاء الرعايه من خلال
انتقالهم الى الحافله وبعد
طولهم الى الحافلات سوف يتم ايضا نقلهم
عبر المقر الفندقيه التي خصصتها الخارجيه
السعوديه وهي تتجاوز
قرابه العشره فنادق وارتفعت اعداد الفنادق
بعد ان كانت 4 فنادق ووصلت الى قرابه
العشره فنادق باعداد تجاوزت
4000 شخص تم اجلؤهم او تم توفير مساكن لهم
فندقيه منذ وصولهم الى السعوديه طبعا هناك
ايضا القنصليات والسفرات او البعثات قد
دبلوماسيه والمنظمات
الاممي مثل الام منظمات او منظمات الدوليه
مثل منظمه
الامم المتحده استعانت بالسعوديه في تسهيل
اجلاء الرعاياها الى مدينه جده وبعد ذلك
غادروا في الاسبوع الماضي الى بلدانهم
ايضا هناك البعثات الدبلوماسيه قامت
بمغادره او ايضا
عمليات اجلاء لراياها وبعد ذلك مغادرتهم
من جده الى بلدانهم بسلام وامان الاعداد
في حقيقه كثيره هناك ايضا ما يمنحونها
وهؤلاء الرعايه يمنحون تاشيرات طوارئ وهي
تاشيرات تمكنهم من الدخول الى السعوديه
وكذلك هي التي سوف تمكنهم من مغادرتها عبر
الطائرات التي
يستقلونها سواء عبر طائرات بلادهم او عبر
طائرات عسكريه يتم مغادرتها من قائده
الملك عبد الله الجويه الى بلدانهم طبعا
ايضا هناك بعض الاشخاص او
ايضا لا يحملون الجنسيات او لا يحملون
وثائق او ثبوتات فيتم منحهم ثبوتات وكذلك
بعض الاثباتات سواء للزات او الوثائق التي
تمكنهم من الدخول الى السعوديه اضافه الى
التاشيرات التي هي تاشيرات طوارئ حتى
يتمكنون من المغادره بسلام وامان لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات